around twenty four thousand two hundred
and fifty nine to the nearest hundred to
the nearest hundred you're going to find
that doing these problems are pretty
straightforward
but what I want to do is just think
about what it means to round to the
nearest hundred so I'm going to do is
I'm going to draw a number line let me
draw a number line here and I'm just
going to mark off the hundreds on the
number line so maybe we have maybe we
have let's say we have 24,000 let's say
this is 24,000 100 and then we go to
24,000 200 then we go to 24,000 300 and
we go to twenty four thousand four
hundred I think you see what I mean when
I'm only marking off the hundreds I'm
going up by increments of a hundred now
on this number line where is twenty four
thousand two hundred and fifty nine so
if we look at the number line it's more
than twenty four thousand two hundred
and it's less than twenty four thousand
three hundred and it's two hundred and
fifty nine so fifty nine if this
distance right here is a hundred fifty
nine is right about there is right about
there so that is where our number is
that is twenty four thousand two hundred
and fifty nine so when someone asks you
to round to the nearest hundred they're
literally saying round to one of these
increments of a hundred that or round to
whichever increment of one hundred then
it is closest to and if you look at it
right like this if you just eyeball it
you'll actually see that it is closer to
twenty four thousand three hundred then
it is to twenty four thousand two
hundred so when you round it you round
to twenty four thousand three hundred so
if you round to the nearest hundred you
litter the answer literally is twenty
four thousand three hundred now that's
kind of the conceptual understanding of
why it's even called the nearest hundred
the nearest hundred is twenty four
thousand three hundred but every time
you do a problem like this you don't
have to draw a number line and go
through this whole process although you
might want to think about it an easier
process or maybe a more mechanical
process is you literally look at the
number so let me write it down again
twenty four thousand two
159 we want to round to the nearest
hundred so you look at the hundreds
place this is the hundreds place right
here and when we round that means we
don't want any digits we only want zeros
after the hundreds place so what you do
is you look at the place one less than
the place you're rounding to this is the
hundreds place so you look at the five
right there and if this number is five
or greater if it's five six seven eight
or nine you round up so five or greater
you round up you round up and so
rounding up in this situation it is five
it is five or greater so rounding up
means that we go to 24,000 I'll write
the 24,000 and one since we're rounding
up we make the two into a three we
increment it by one so rounding up so
it's twenty four thousand three hundred
twenty four thousand three hundred
that's what we mean by rounding up and
just as a kind of a counter example if I
had twenty four thousand two hundred and
forty nine twenty four thousand two
hundred and forty nine and I wanted to
round to the nearest hundred I would say
okay I want to round to the nearest
hundred let me look at the tens place
let's place one level to the right it is
not five or greater so I will round down
I will round round down and when you
round down be careful doesn't mean you
decrease this too it literally means you
just only have the two just get rid of
everything after it so it becomes twenty
four thousand two hundred that's the
process where you round down if you
round up becomes twenty four thousand
three hundred and it makes sense twenty
four thousand two hundred and forty nine
is going to be sitting right over here
someplace
so it's going to be closer to twenty
four thousand two hundred twenty four
thousand two hundred would be the
nearest hundred when we round down in
this case for the case of the problem
twenty four thousand two hundred and
fifty nine the nearest hundred is twenty
four thousand three hundred we round up